hello and welcome to this video with the
Blitz game against next draw let's do
this maybe I can transpose too ok let's
just go for kings in yen why not it's a
good opening for white after all it can
go if I've of course to give that some
give this some independent character he
doesn't going to try this line here but
should be three Bishop e2 I recently saw
an idea there that i found interesting
night a 6g 495 bishop f3 ok yeah this is
a typical case of Kings Indian gone
wrong right now has a pretty substantial
advantage it's not as bad as it can be
in the typical Petrosian clamp the f
pawn that is on f4 now is on f7 but
still this position is very one-sided as
black can only sit and wait what kind of
move is that when that is totally wrong
1b6
Wow okay um so let's see c6 already or
not anyway this is just good night has
to go over yeah it's interesting a hey
the question is that I can do that I
mean v6c 6 is just good for wide that's
very cute okay so let's see let's
completely protect g4 ID for and now the
King side and the queenside will
ultimately be falling like a five for
example a key is a threat of knight c6
effort have to attend to that the only
thing that might happen is some kind of
sacrifice on d5 g4 somewhere why it is
not cautious enough if he is cautious
enough he will win the game ok I can do
this
night b5 Queen B 6 not quite sure what
the point is I don't say okay I don't
have I don't have a great discovery look
b7 however it is good
might be 50 how are you not losing
everything
Queen 86 97 s pretty convincing
it's not just the rook the queen is
completely trapped yeah black was almost
having a lost structure after moved 10
or a very bad structure hard to
understand where someone would go
against resign voluntarily really keen a
jade is already slightly weird not quite
sure what the point is even after in all
the rules that say that neither three or
so yeah now this I don't believe it each
form I mean there are spaces pretty
important in chess and I have plenty I
could have taken g6 by the way I didn't
didn't do that I would have been
probably even better but anyway this is
this is just very very bad for black I
can just play I mean this is all so
strange runs right into this yeah it
would have been funny to see this one
but this position here is probably and
probably almost the wind for white
because I will be able to sacrifice on a
5 him and ultimately win with those two
pawns yeah night to a for one night to
see four and then taking on a five this
really has been played in in games it's
not a new idea or night f 2 nite to be
three and then Bishop second a five the
P sacrifice will ultimately probably
decide the game and go into this and now
yeah now this is basically gone and with
it the game can simply an unplayable
unplayable opening line yeah King edge
eat already who and this this is this is
really bad now okay well thanks for
watching